This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的种种迹象。经历一些苦难，你就能在另一端破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. that's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《2%》。在《Look Back at It》播客节目中。从1979年开始，对当时的我和我而言，这都是一个意义重大的时刻。84年对我也非常重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段岁月的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black. black people. Listen to look back at it on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。黑人群体。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《Look Back at It》。大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位知悉内情的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人身披铠甲。这向全世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听并学习《艰难成长的教训》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我只在测试上动了一次手脚。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the podcast. the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《受困之爱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today we are going to be talking about closure, what it is, what it isn't. It's very elusive nature, whether we need it and how to find your self-closure without needing another person's input or needing someone to have all the answers for you.
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到本期播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目。今天我们要聊聊“释怀”（closure）：什么是释怀，什么不是释怀。它非常难以捉摸的本质，我们是否需要释怀，以及如何在不需要他人介入或不需要别人为你提供所有答案的情况下，找到自我释怀的方法。
Closure, I think, is such an interesting concept in our 20s because there are so many storylines that we will live out, so many relationships and situations that will not have a neat conclusion. as much as we might want them to, not every relationship is going to finish on a good note. Of course, when I talk about closure, most of us do think about relationships, we think about love, we think about that period after a relationship ends,
我认为，“释怀”在我们二十多岁时是一个非常有趣的概念，因为我们会经历那么多的人生剧情，会有那么多没有完美结局的关系和状况。尽管我们可能希望它们能有个好结局，但并非每段关系都会以美好的音符收尾。当然，当我谈到释怀时，我们大多数人想到的确实是人际关系，我们会想到爱情，会想到恋爱关系结束后的那段时间，
where we are left with thousands of questions. Did they really love me? What did I do wrong? What do they think of me now? why was I not enough? Honestly, the list is endless and I think the need for closure is a lot like grief. It is lost or misplaced love, a love that really lingers on. But beyond those romantic relationships, we can also require closure at the end of platonic relationships and friendships. I think friendships always seem to be painted as less important by our society,
那时我们留下了成千上万个问题。他们真的爱过我吗？我做错了什么？他们现在怎么看我？为什么我做得还不够好？老实说，这样的问题列举不完。我认为，对释怀的需求在很大程度上类似于悲伤。它是失去或错置的爱，是一份久久挥之不去的爱。但除了这些浪漫的恋爱关系，我们在柏拉图式的亲密关系和友谊结束时，也同样需要释怀。我认为，在我们的社会中，友谊似乎总是被描绘成不那么重要的存在，
something that we just expect to follow along with us in life, whilst our romantic relationships are really the main attraction. But I really do truly believe that they can hurt so deeply when they come to an end, probably because we never expect our friendships to end in that way. We never expect to go through a friendship breakup. Or, you know, I've heard so many stories of lifelong friendships where the other person suddenly ghost the first. or goes completely silent or friendship breakups that are so much worse than the heartbreak that we experience from romantic relationships. When we are that connected with someone, when we spend so much time with them, we bond over everything, we talk all the time. Seeing those connections,
仿佛它们只是我们在生活中顺理成章、一路相伴的东西，而我们的浪漫关系才是真正的重头戏。但我真的坚信，当友谊走到尽头时，它们带来的痛苦可以如此深重，这大概是因为我们从没想过我们的友谊会以那种方式结束。我们从未想过要经历一次“朋友圈断交”。或者，你知道的，我听过太多关于终身友谊的故事，其中一个人突然对另一个人实行了冷暴力（ghosting），或者彻底人间蒸发，或者友情破裂所带来的痛苦，远胜于我们在浪漫关系中经历的心碎。当我们与某人的联系如此紧密，当我们花那么多时间陪伴彼此，我们在方方面面建立羁绊，无话不谈。看到这些连接，
whether they are platonic or romantic, seeing them crumble is really upsetting, especially when we are left feeling very confused and unable to seek clarity. In those words, we're not able to seek clarity. In those moments, we want closure. We feel like it is the only thing that will help us come to terms with these events. But although we might want closure, do we really need it as much as we think we do? And when we say that we're looking for closure, what exactly does that entail? And is it maybe slightly naive for us to think that the person who caused us so much pain and disappointment is going to be the same person who can provide us with the answers,
无论是柏拉图式的还是浪漫的，看到它们分崩离析真的让人十分沮丧，尤其是当我们感到无比困惑、无法寻求清晰的真相时。在那些时刻，我们无法寻求清晰的真相。在那些时刻，我们渴望释怀。我们觉得这是唯一能帮助我们接受这些事件的事情。但是，尽管我们可能渴望释怀，我们真的像自己想象的那么需要它吗？当我们说我们在寻找释怀时，那究竟意味着什么？而且，认为那个给我们带来如此多痛苦和失望的人，会是那个能为我们提供答案、
that will let us heal? I don't necessarily think so. So that's really what I want to focus on in today's episode. Do we need someone else to provide us with closure or can we provide it for ourselves? I think that my opinion is quite obvious, but before we get into that, let's look into some of the psychological origins of this concept of closure and make sure that the foundations of our understanding are strong. Closure essentially refers to our need to make sense. of a situation and feel like it has a solid conclusion. In psychology, the need for closure is seen as a motivation to find an answer to an ambiguous situation because as humans, as we know, we are not particularly good at navigating uncertainty. So this motivation to find an answer,
让我们得以疗愈的人，这种想法是不是稍微有点天真？我倒不一定这么认为。所以这正是我想要在今天的节目中重点探讨的内容。我们需要别人来为我们提供释怀，还是我们能自己成全自己？我想我的观点已经相当明显了，但在我们深入探讨之前，让我们先来看看“释怀”这个概念的一些心理学起源，确保我们理解的基础足够扎实。从本质上讲，释怀指的是我们有一种让情况合情合理、
it is enhanced by what we see is the benefits of this, right? So an increased ability to predict what might happen, being able to remove some of those fears. feeling certain of where we stand with someone. Really, it's about finding a way and finding a place for these memories. And social psychologists in particular suggest that people tend to have a need to view their relationships as a whole, that they are a complete story, they have a beginning, they have a middle, and they have an end. And when a relationship concludes, the mind seeks to fill in any gaps before moving on
并感觉它有一个明确结局的需求。在心理学中，对释怀的需求被视为一种寻找答案的动机，以应对模棱两可的情况，因为正如我们所知，作为人类，我们在应对不确定性方面并不是特别擅长。因此，这种寻找答案的动机，被我们认为能带来的好处所放大，对吧？比如，增强了预测可能发生事情的能力，能够消除其中一些恐惧。确信自己与某人的关系处于什么位置。说到底，这是为了给这些记忆找到一种方式和一个安放之处。社会心理学家尤其指出，人们往往有一种需求，希望将自己的关系视为一个整体，认为它们是一个完整的故事情节，有开头、有过程、也有结局。当一段关系结束时，心灵会在继续前行之前，试图填补任何空白，
so that it can find that ending. In other words, we need that closure to essentially finish off the story. And when we are left without an ending, either because the relationship ended quite abruptly, we didn't see it coming, you ended on a fight that you never resolved, or there was just radio silence, we don't know where to place that memory because it still feels like it's ongoing. It's an active storyline. Our minds have this open chapter. and this lack of a conclusion keeps us going back and returning again and again and again, wanting to find more answers by searching through our memories, wanting to find a resting place for this relationship and for what it has become.
以便找到那个结局。换句话说，我们需要这种释怀来基本上为这个故事画上句号。当我们没有得到一个结局时，无论是由于关系结束得相当突然、我们始料未及，还是因为你们在一次从未解决的争吵中结束，又或者只是一片死寂般的沉默，我们不知道该把这段记忆放在哪里，因为它感觉仍然在继续。这是一个活跃的故事情节。我们的脑海里翻开着这个未完的章节，
We all have, as humans, that individual drive for closure, but that need and that drive differs between us. So mainly it differs according to intensity. and the intensity of our need for closure, this depends largely on our personality. So people with that intense need for closure, they may be used to being in control and they prefer life to go as planned. They may feel really distressed by uncertainty and might really challenge their sense of safety and well-being to not have the answers to a question.
而这种缺乏结局的状态让我们不断地回过头去，一次又一次、一遍又一遍地重温，想要通过翻找记忆来寻找更多答案，想要为这段关系以及它所变成的模样找到一个歇息之所。我们每个人，作为人类，都有那种对释怀的内在驱动力，但这种需求和驱动力在每个人之间是有差异的。所以，它主要在强度上有所不同，
And in the 1990s, these three psychologists actually came up with the need for closure scale, which can be used to really categorize people based on a number of questions and determine where we kind of all sit on this spectrum of obtaining closure, what lengths we will go to find closure at the end of a relationship or at the end of some situation. So those of us who really need closure often make a lot of assumptions or false judgments or shut down as soon as a relationship is over in order to just provide ourselves with the ending without waiting around for someone else to come in and challenge what we feel was the reason for this relationship not working or what we feel was the reason that this had to end. The answers that we come up with, the conclusion
而我们对释怀需求的强度，很大程度上取决于我们的性格。因此，那些对释怀有着强烈需求的人，可能习惯于掌控一切，他们更喜欢生活按计划进行。他们可能会对不确定性感到非常苦恼，而无法得到某个问题的答案，可能会真正挑战他们的安全感和幸福感。而在20世纪90年代，这三位心理学家实际上提出了“寻求释怀量表”（need for closure scale），该量表可用于根据许多问题对人们进行真正分类，并确定我们大家在获取释怀这一光谱上的大致位置，以及为了在一段关系或某种情况结束时找到释怀，我们会付出多大的努力。因此，我们当中那些真正需要释怀的人，往往会做出很多假设、错误的判断，或者在关系结束的那一刻立即关闭心扉，
that we reach, it might, you know, it might not be entirely correct. It might be based on a lot of false premises. But at least in our minds, the story is over. We have a nice bookend to this relationship, to this situation. In contrast, sometimes we observe individuals who avoid closure, almost as a way to continue to suspend the relationship in space and time. So the movie 500 Days of Summer, if you've seen it, and if you haven't, you really should go and watch it, it's quite good. But this movie, cult classic, it's an excellent example of someone who does not have a high
以便只为自己提供一个结局，而不去等待别人介入并挑战我们所认为的这段关系没有走下去的原因，或者我们所认为的这件事不得不结束的原因。我们得出的答案、我们达到的结论，它可能，你知道的，它可能并不完全正确。它可能是基于许多错误的前提。但至少在我们的脑海里，故事结束了。我们为这段关系、为这种情况画上了一个漂亮的句号。相比之下，有时我们会观察到一些刻意回避释怀的人，这几乎成了他们将关系在时空中继续悬置的一种方式。所以，如果你看过电影《和莎莫的500天》（500 Days of Summer），如果没看过，你真的应该去看一看，它相当不错。但是这部电影，作为一部邪典经典，是一个极好的例子，展现了一个并不具有高
need for closure, in fact, avoids closure. So Tom, the main character, he really remains suspended in the happy memories of the relationship and he's fixated on them almost as a way to stay connected with his ex. Closure signifies the end. But if you are still anticipating something more, if you are unable to rectify your feelings for someone, even when you know it's time to move on, if you have these expectations that you might get back together, sometimes you actually continue to deprive yourself of closure in order to stay in the potential of the relationship. That's because our innate need to avoid closure in some of these instances
释怀需求、甚至回避释怀的人。因此，作为主角的汤姆，他确实留恋在关系的快乐记忆中，并且对它们执迷不悟，几乎以此作为与前任保持联系的一种方式。释怀标志着结束。但如果你仍然在期待更多，如果你即使在知道是时候放手时也无法理顺自己对某人的感情，如果你抱有可能会复合的期望，有时你实际上是在剥夺自己释怀的机会，以便停留在关系的各种可能性中。这是因为我们在其中某些情况下避免释怀的内在需求，
is controlled by our desire to avoid the negative consequences that come along with that. So, for example, once you acknowledge that, yes, this relationship is over, this person does not want to talk to me. I do not want to talk to them. Acknowledging that fully means that you have to start processing what that means for you, the pain that that might bring. So we elongate the situation in order to avoid that. There's actually another little interesting facet of this that is kind of the fun fact for this episode.
受控于我们避免随之而来的负面后果的愿望。例如，一旦你承认，是的，这段关系结束了，这个人不想跟我说话。我也不想跟他们说话。完全承认这一点意味着你必须开始处理这对你意味着什么，这可能会带来的痛苦。因此，我们拉长了这种情况以避免面对它。其实还有一个有趣的方面，这也是这集节目的趣味冷知识。
People, these types of people who don't really have that need for closure, they've done some studies on what that really means for the rest of their personality, and they found that, and some studies conducted on the correlation between the need for closure and creativity levels, people who avoid closure are significantly more creative. Maybe that's because of their appreciation of deep emotions, or the fact that they are more comfortable with things being uncertain. So they're able to transfer that uncertainty and that kind of open-endedness into their art or what they're creating.
人们，这些真正没有那种释怀需求的人，他们对这在他们性格的其余部分中究竟意味着什么做了一些研究，他们发现，并且在对释怀需求与创造力水平之间的相关性进行的一些研究中发现，回避释怀的人明显更具有创造力。这可能是因为他们对深层情感的欣赏，或者是因为他们更能泰然处之于不确定的事物。因此，他们能够将这种不确定性和那种开放式的结局转化为他们的艺术或他们的创作。
So a little fun fact, that's not to say that depriving ourselves of closure, either unconsciously or not, is all good and has a lot of benefits. I actually think that a lot of us do get to a point, even if you have a low need for closure, we do get to a point where we can no longer live in the past. And maybe our lack of closure is preventing us from moving on. or it is keeping us in a very emotionally unavailable place. I think we commonly see this with people straight out of a long-term relationship who actually haven't yet figured out exactly why the relationship didn't work. Because of that, they don't necessarily know what maybe needs to change, but more often than not, you still have one foot stuck in that past relationship taking up emotional,
所以这是一个有趣的冷知识，但这并不是说剥夺我们自己的释怀——无论是无意识的还是有意的——就全是好事并且有很多好处。我实际上认为，我们中的许多人确实会达到这样一个地步，即使你对释怀的需求很低，我们也会达到一个再也无法活在过去的时刻。也许我们缺乏释怀正在阻止我们继续前进，或者它让我们停留在一种非常缺乏情感准备的状态中。我认为我们经常在刚结束一段长期关系的那些人身上看到这一点，他们实际上还没有弄清楚这段关系为什么没有走下去。正因为如此，他们不一定知道可能需要改变什么，但通常情况下，你仍然有一只脚陷在那段过去的感情中，占据着本可以更好地用于别处的情感、
mental and psychological space that might be better devoted for something else, not just to someone else, but for something else. And it's super frustrating. I've talked about this a bit before, but I had this weird situation ship a few years back with someone, and it was so emotionally exhausting, it was draining, it left me in such a bad place mentally. I had no self-confidence. I could barely speak to anybody, and it took me so much time to recover and so much time to find that piece and closure that I needed more so than when I'd ended my previous long-term relationship. And the reason why was because of how many what-ifs were left over. At least in my relationship, we kind of had the chance to really take this connection to its final destination, if that makes
精神和心理空间，这不仅是指针对另一个人，而是为了别的某种东西。这超级令人沮丧。我以前稍微谈过这个，但在几年前，我和某人有过一段奇怪的“非正式关系”（situationship），它是如此的情感消耗，如此精疲力竭，它把我带到了一个精神状态极差的境地。我毫无自信。我几乎无法和任何人说话，我花了大量的时间才恢复过来，花了好长的时间才找到我需要的平静和释怀，这甚至超过了我结束上一段长期关系的时候。原因就在于留下了太多的“如果……会怎样”（what-ifs）。至少在我那段恋爱关系中，我们有机会真正将这段羁绊带到它的终点，如果这说得通的话。
sense. Like, we lived out the journey that we were meant to go on. We had tried to make it work. It didn't. There was nothing left to say. There was nothing left to do. The end of the story was written very quickly. But with that situation, because the entire relationship had been so tumultuous, the conclusion, or what I thought was the conclusion, was equally confusing. You know, was it me? Was it him? Was it just circumstances? Was it timing? In hindsight, I really can't believe I spent so much time, so many months thinking about this person. But I also realized that there were some parts of that relationship that always meant I was never going to get the answers that I needed at the end. Or so I thought. I think when we are in this moment of grief and ambiguity and sadness,
就像我们经历了一场注定要经历的旅程。我们曾试图让它维持下去。但失败了。没有什么可说的了。没有什么可做的了。故事的结局写得非常快。但在那种非正式关系中，由于整段关系一直如此动荡不安，结局——或者我认为是结局的东西——同样令人困惑。你知道的，是我的问题吗？是他的问题吗？仅仅是环境造成的吗？是时机的问题吗？事后回想起来，我真的不敢相信我花了那么多时间、好几个月的时间去想这个人。但我也意识到，那段关系的某些部分注定了我在结束时永远无法得到我需要的答案。或者我是这么认为的。我认为当我们处于这种悲伤、模棱两可和难过的时刻时，
we like to believe in the idea of a quick fix. And we fixate on this premise that there is something we don't know that can explain it all away and take away all these feelings. There is some answer out there that's going to make us feel better. And we place a lot of hope in someone else's ability to reach our emotional conclusions for us. I think we obviously all need closure. It is a human need, but we don't necessarily need someone else to give it to us. Our solution to the closure problem doesn't always lie with our ex or a former friend or any explanation that they can provide us. In fact, I think you are probably the only person who is going to be able to bring that for yourself. Even if you don't realize it in the moment, in hindsight,
我们倾向于相信“快速修补”的想法。我们执着于这样一个前提：有些我们不知道的事情可以解释这一切，并带走所有这些情绪。总会有某个答案能让我们感觉好受一些。我们将太多的希望寄托在别人替我们得出情感结论的能力上。我想我们显然都需要释怀。这是一种人类的需求，但我们不一定需要别人来给予我们。我们对释怀问题的解决办法并不总是依赖于我们的前任、曾经的朋友或他们能提供的任何解释。事实上，我认为你可能是唯一一个能够为自己带来这一点的人。即使你当时没有意识到，事后回想起来，
nothing that someone else has said has made you feel any better. Normally, it's just that you have been able to integrate that into your idea of the relationship and your idea of the conclusion and write that ending for yourself. So there's a few reasons why I don't think that we should rely on other people to bring us closure. Firstly, their actions were in some ways the closure that you needed. Their inability to treat you with respect or their fickleness, their inconsistent, their cruelty, even at times, that is really the evidence that all along, this person did not have the emotional maturity to navigate an adult relationship with you, right? Like, a lot of the time,
别人所说的话并没有让你感觉好受一点。通常情况下，只是因为你已经能够将这些纳入你对关系的理解、你对结局的想法中，并为自己写下了那个结局。因此，有几个原因让我觉得我们不应该依赖别人来给我们带来释怀。首先，他们的行为在某种程度上就是你所需要的释怀。他们无法以尊重对待你，或者他们的反复无常、他们的不一致、甚至有时他们的残忍，这确实是所有证据，表明这个人自始至终都不具备与你经营一段成年人关系的成熟度，对吧？就像，很多时候，
if you are left without answers at the end of a relationship, something has kind of not gone wrong, but there is something that they could have provided you, that they could have spoken to about along the way that they chose not to. And I think secondly, like I mentioned before, you are relying on the same person who hurt you in the first place to heal that very wound that they created, either intentionally or unintentionally. I think the irony of this is best understood, you know, through metaphor. If you fall off a ladder and you break your back, you are not going to climb back up that same ladder with the hope that you will fall off it again and break your back back to the way that it was before. Do you know what I mean?
如果你在一段关系结束时没有得到答案，某种程度上并不是出了什么问题，而是有些东西是他们本可以在这一路上与你沟通却选择不沟通的。我认为其次，就像我之前提到的，你是在依赖那个最初伤害你的人来治愈他们自己造成的、无论是刻意还是无意创伤。我认为这种反讽通过隐喻能被最好地理解，你知道的。如果你从梯子上摔下来摔断了背，你不会再爬上同一个梯子，希望自己能再次摔下来，把背摔回原来的样子。你知道我的意思吗？
Like, this person has obviously created some pain and has injured you in some way. I don't necessarily think that they can undo that. They might not even have the answer that you want because they don't know it themselves. They may not even be able to articulate their actual feelings well enough to provide you with the clarity that you need. And there's also no guarantee that they're going to be honest with you either. So you are relying on a faulty or an unwilling messenger for your emotional and mental sanity. I also saw this really beautiful quote the other day that I think expresses this very well. Life is short.
就像，这个人显然制造了一些痛苦，并以某种方式伤害了你。我不认为他们一定能撤销这一切。他们甚至可能没有你想要的答案，因为他们自己也不知道。他们甚至可能无法足够好地表达他们真实的情感，来为你提供你需要的清晰度。而且也没有保证他们会对你诚实。所以你是在把你的情感和精神理智寄托在一个有缺陷或不愿配合的信使身上。我前几天还看到了这句非常美的名言，我认为它很好地表达了这一点。人生苦短。
I don't think that you should wait around for apologies. Your peace is worth more than their acknowledgement. If you're looking for them to say sorry, if you're looking for them to not just apologize, but make some kind of amends, I don't think you're ever going to truly believe that anyways. And I don't think it's going to undo anything that has already happened. At least they won't be able to undo it. Once again, sadly, it's back to you.
我不认为你应该苦苦等待道歉。你的平静比他们的承认更有价值。如果你在等他们说对不起，如果你在等他们不仅道歉，而且做出某种弥补，我想你无论如何都不会真正相信这一点的。而且我不认为这会抹杀已经发生的任何事情。至少他们无法抹杀这一切。再说一次，悲哀的是，这又回到了你身上。
And thirdly, and for me personally, this is the most important reason we shouldn't rely on others for closure, is that sometimes we use closure as a proxy for something else that we actually want. We think that we need to reach out to them just one more time, grab a coffee with them just once more in order to get closure. But really, what you want to do is just see them again because you're not ready to move on. But you're evoking this idea of closure as an excuse. I'm not trying to call you out.
第三个原因，对我个人而言，这也是我们不应依赖他人获得释怀的最重要原因，那就是有时我们将“释怀”当作我们真正想要的某种东西的借口。我们认为我们需要再联系他们一次，再和他们喝一次咖啡，只是为了得到释怀。但实际上，你只想再见他们一面，因为你还没有准备好继续前进。但你却以释怀的概念作为借口。我不是在试图揭穿你。
I'm just saying from experience, I would do this. I'd be like, oh, you know, I just have a few more questions about the end of our relationship. But really, I didn't. I knew everything that I needed to know. I just wanted to see them. You have convinced yourself that you have good intentions when actually underneath this urge is a true desire to reconnect. And this pattern is keeping you stuck in the memories of the relationship.
我只是根据经验说，我以前也会这样做。我会想，哦，你知道的，我只是对我们关系的结束还有几个问题。但实际上，我根本没有。我需要的我都已经知道了。我只是想见见他们。你已经说服自己你有着良好的意愿，而实际上在这个冲动之下的，是重新建立联系的真实渴望。这种模式让你深陷于这段关系的记忆中无法自拔。
It's making you feel like it's not quite over yet that there's more to come. You're left kind of discussing your relationship with this person. You're looking for answers that you know they can never give you. And when you repeatedly go back to this person with more excuses to catch up, you are in the closure cycle. we are not letting the connection fade away from our memory and our brains. So in psychology, particularly in cognitive psychology, there is this idea known as long-term potentiation. And it has to do with how our neurons make and replace connections and pathways in the brain. So the more we use a connection, for example, the more we talk to someone and see
它让你觉得一切还没有完全结束，还有更多的事情要发生。你最终陷入了与这个人的关系探讨中。你在寻找那些你知道他们永远无法给你的答案。当你一次又一次地以更多的借口去追上这个人时，你就陷入了释怀的循环中。我们没有让这份羁绊从我们的记忆和大脑中逐渐淡去。所以在心理学中，特别是在认知心理学中，有一个被称为“长时程增强”（long-term potentiation）的概念。它与我们的神经元如何在脑海中建立和替换连接与通路有关。因此，我们越是使用一个连接，例如，我们越是和某人交谈、看到
them and interact with them and bond with them, the more we use it, the stronger that. neural connection becomes. When that relationship disappears, the neural pathway is not stimulated as much by an external presence or stimuli. So it's used less and less until it begins to fade and be replaced inevitably by something that is more important. That is a natural part of the recovery process, specifically after the end of a relationship. It's the reason why we say that time heals because it quite literally does. It heals us by letting our brain do what it does best, which is prioritise what is important and what is not important. And if this person is no longer part of your life, we want our brain to deprioritize
他们、与他们互动并建立羁绊，我们使用得越多，那个神经连接就变得越强。当这段关系消失时，神经通路就不再受到外部存在或刺激的那么多刺激。因此它被越来越少地使用，直到它开始消退，并不可避免地被更重要的东西所取代。这是恢复过程的自然组成部分，特别是在一段关系结束之后。这就是为什么我们说时间能治愈一切，因为它字面意思上确实如此。它通过让大脑做它最擅长的事情来治愈我们，那就是区分什么是重要的，什么是不重要的。如果这个人不再是你生活的一部分，我们希望我们的大脑降低
the information that it has about this individual. When we continue to find opportunities to talk to them, to reach out, to call, see this person, all we are doing is keeping this connection alive. We are keeping it strong. We are keeping that pathway and those memories. present and we aren't letting ourselves move on the way that we should. This neural explanation is not to claim that you shouldn't reach out if you really need to, but I do believe that one closure conversation is probably enough. You have a right to ask for closure, but you need to ensure that you want it for the right reasons. And I also don't think you should expect to leave the conversation feeling completely sure of yourself and renewed. Those expectations, once again,
它关于这个个体的信息的优先级。当我们继续寻找机会和他们交谈、联系、打电话、见这个人时，我们所做的一切就是让这个连接保持活力。我们让它保持强韧。我们让那条通路和那些记忆保持新鲜，而没有让我们自己以应有的方式继续前进。这种神经学上的解释并不是要声称如果你真的需要的话就不应该去联系，但我确实相信，一次释怀的对话可能就足够了。你有权要求释怀，但你需要确保你是为了正确的理由而需要它。而且我也不认为你应该期望离开谈话时对自我感到完全确定且焕然一新。这些期望，再次强调，
contribute to the closure seeking cycle. Because when you go into it, thinking, I just need to hear this one thing and I'll be okay, it's never just that one thing that you need to hear. And so you'll keep going back, wanting more and more, waiting for the right thing to be said when it won't be said at all. So when going into that conversation, if you choose to have a closure chat, make sure firstly that you have a time limit do not find yourself talking to them for six seven eight hours staying over you know going for a long drive like don't find yourself in a situation that is reminiscent of your relationship you need to have your questions ready and you need to have your intentions clear what are you actually hoping to get out of this is there actually
会助长寻求释怀的循环。因为当你带着这种想法进去时，心想，“我只需要听到这一句话，我就会没事的”，你永远不会只需要听到那一句话。所以你会不断地回去，想要更多，等待着被说出正确的话，而这句话根本不会被说出口。所以在进入那场谈话时，如果你选择进行一次释怀谈话，首先要确保你设定了一个时间限制——不要发现自己和他们聊了六、七、八个小时，留宿过夜，你知道的，去兜风——不要让自己陷入让人联想起你们那段关系的境地。你需要准备好你的问题，你需要让你的意图清晰：你实际上希望从这次谈话中得到什么？是否真的
a reason that you need to be there right now and you need to be discussing this with them Remember as well that this is also a controlled conversation. This is not a time to try and get them back. It's not a time to bring up old arguments. This is a space for understanding and moving forward. It's also important to acknowledge that there are a lot of situations where we are not provided with that opportunity to talk it through with someone else, especially in some of those situations that we spoke of before where the other person has just chosen
有一个你需要出现在那里并与他们讨论这个问题的理由？同时要记住，这也是一场受控的谈话。这不是试图让他们回心转意的时候。这不是重提旧争论的时候。这是一个用于理解和向前迈进的空间。同样重要的是要承认，在许多情况下，我们并没有被提供与其他人坐下来谈一谈的机会，尤其是在我们之前谈到的一些情况下，另一个人只是选择
to break all contact they've chosen to block you to ghost you and this might sound controversial but as hard as that is that is their right to do i usually see these situations and friendships when someone has actually just been unable to set boundaries or communicate maybe they are very conflict-averse so something has been bothering them for a while they just don't know how to talk to you about it. You remain unaware. It's not like you've done anything wrong. Maybe you have, but you just haven't been given an opportunity to rectify the situation or to apologize. And so this person eventually snaps. And their only option they see in their mind is to just go completely no contact with you. I know it doesn't feel fair that we are left to navigate the aftermath of this
切断所有联系，他们选择拉黑你、对你冷暴力。这听起来可能很有争议，但尽管这很难，那是他们的权利。我通常在友情中看到这些情况，当某人实际上根本无法设定边界或进行沟通时。也许他们非常抗拒冲突，所以有些事情困扰他们一段时间了，他们只是不知道该怎么跟你谈。你对此一无所知。这并不是说你做了什么错事。也许你确实做了，但你只是没有被给与纠正情况或道歉的机会。于是这个人最终崩溃了。在他们脑海中，他们看到的唯一选择就是与你彻底失联。我知道，让我们自己去面对这一切的余波，这感觉很不公平，
ourselves. But we cannot control what other people see as best for them. What you you can control is what you do next. And I think it's your turn to do what's best for you and to find a way to move forward and provide yourself once again with closure. So that is what I want to discuss next. How do we find closure without reliance on others? How do we move on successfully? Well, all of that and more after this short break. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
但我们无法控制别人认为什么对他们最好。你能控制的是你接下来要做什么。我认为轮到你去做对你最好的事，去寻找继续前进的方法，并再次为自己提供释怀。所以这就是我接下来要讨论的内容。我们如何在不依赖他人的情况下找到释怀？我们如何成功地继续前进？好吧，这一切以及更多内容，将在短暂的广告之后揭晓。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
健身以及在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中培养抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越统治着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上具有炎症性。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TW0% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill?
我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就能在另一端破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《2%》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（double-tapped）莉儿·金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。这他妈跟莉儿·金有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段岁月的。包括最近一期节目，我们与马马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的“快克”（crack）毒品。澄清一下，对我很重要不仅仅是因为快克。我也愿意在白天聊聊快克，不过为了让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。
I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years
我开始看出这其中有一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你补充完那句话。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是
for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness, month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in
美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我所谈论的是
the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们却仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个在世的好人很重要，还是你成为一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
我希望你真正出于纯粹的目的成为一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》中，就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于父子鉴定丑闻的中心。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see
随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我只在测试上动了一次手脚。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到
what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through, the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Maranjini. My mind was blown.
他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·马拉尼尼（Michael Maranjini）。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉
on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Providing ourselves with the emotional, psychological, mental closure that we need.
欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《受困之爱》播客。为自己提供我们所需的情感、心理和精神上的释怀。
Doing it all by ourselves, officially closing a chapter in this book, is not going to come without some challenges. I know this all too well. I'm sure that you do as well if you're listening to this episode. And there are so many times where we sit back and I think just wish and pray that we could be over it by now. We just want to be over it. We're ready to just have moved on, but sometimes we're also not willing to do the work to get there, because the path through is often, you know, the path that is hardest. But I have five tips and kind of pieces of instruction for you. And I think
完全靠我们自己做到这一点，正式合上这本书中的一个章节，并非不会伴随着一些挑战。对此我深有体会。如果你正在听这期节目，我确信你也一样。有很多时候，我们坐在那里，我只想说，只希望并祈祷我们现在就能释怀。我们只想彻底放下。我们已经准备好继续前行了，但有时我们也不愿意为此付出努力，因为通往那里的道路通常是，你知道的，最艰难的道路。但我有五个建议和一些指导意见给你。我认为
following this process releases a lot of the grief and the anguish that otherwise keeps us quite trapped in the past and quite trapped in the closure cycle. So my tips are as follows. We're going to talk about changing your mindset around what the end of this relationship has brought you. Second, how to not be afraid of negative emotions. Thirdly, how not to be afraid of memory flare-ups. How to take responsibility. And then finally, how to release the pain that is wanting you to go back and ask more questions and look for more. answers and I have a specific exercise for this that I think is so important it has been so helpful to me in those times that I really needed closure so to begin let's talk about changing your
遵循这个过程可以释放许多悲伤和痛苦，否则这些痛苦会让我们深深地陷在过去和释怀的循环中。所以我的建议如下。我们要讨论改变你对这段关系的结束带给你什么的心态。第二，如何不害怕负面情绪。第三，如何不害怕记忆的突然涌现。如何承担责任。最后，如何释放那个促使你回去问更多问题、寻找更多答案的痛苦，为此我有一个专门的练习，我认为这非常重要，它在我真正需要释怀的那些时刻对我非常有帮助。首先，让我们来谈谈改变
mindset we hear this a lot and I understand that when we hear this we thought people talk about mindset shifts and whatnot it's very easy to dismiss this and just be like that is a that is nonsense that it's a bunch of garbage like let's just skip this step I don't need to change my mindset it's just a terrible situation. I get it and in many ways it is a terrible situation, but we're going to trust the psychology on this and the psychology says that we have control over our cognitions and our thoughts about a situation. And these cognitions can be changed to better suit us. So instead of sitting there and thinking, this is the worst thing that has ever happened to me, this is so terrible, I'm never going to recover from this, I'm never going to find love again,
心态。我们经常听到这句话，我理解当我们听到这个时，当人们谈论心态转变之类的事情时，很容易对此不屑一顾，只想说：这纯粹是无稽之谈，是一堆垃圾，我们跳过这一步吧，我不需要改变心态，这只是一个糟糕的处境。我懂的，在许多方面这确实是一个糟糕的处境，但我们要相信心理学，心理学说我们对自己的认知和对某种情况的想法具有控制力。这些认知是可以改变的，以更好地适应我们。因此，与其坐在那里想，这是我经历过的最糟糕的事情，这太糟糕了，我永远无法从中恢复过来，我再也找不到真爱了，
I'm never going to have a friend as good as her. This is the end for me. Replace those thoughts deliberately with ones that suit you'd better. Yes, it sucks, but this ending was a gift. This has given me things that I wouldn't have imagined for myself. What doors are opening because that relationship ended? What is it teaching you about yourself? I always say that the best beginnings are truly hidden in the endings of things,
我永远不会找到一个像她那样好的朋友了。对我来说一切都结束了。请刻意用更适合你的想法来替换这些想法。是的，这很糟糕，但这个结局是一份礼物。它带给我许多我从未想象过的事情。那段关系的结束为你打开了哪些大门？它在教导你关于自己的什么？我总是说，最好的开始往往隐藏在事物的结局之中，
because it's there that the story really gets to take like so many different turns. It's where the storyline is most open for change. That's the point that you're at right now. I think stop those negative thoughts and replace them with a deliberate thought. So when you think, I just want to get over this, I'm so, this is just the worst thing that's ever happened to me.
因为正是在那里，故事才真正迎来了如此多的不同转折。那是故事情节最向改变敞开的地方。这就是你现在所处的阶段。我认为应该停止那些消极的想法，并用一个刻意的想法取而代之。所以当你想着，“我只想熬过去，我太……这是我经历过的最糟糕的事情。”
Stop and say, this might be the best thing that's ever happened to me. I just can't see it yet. I just don't know what my future looks like and that is really exciting. When you continue to interrupt those negative thoughts and replace them, that repetition will mean that you get to a point someday where it becomes automatic. You don't need to try and convince yourself. You just believe it. You just believe that maybe this happened not for a reason, but there is something that it's going to come out of this, that you would have missed if that relationship had continued.
停下来，然后告诉自己：“这可能是我经历过的最好的事情，只是我还没看出来。我只是不知道我的未来会是什么样，这其实非常令人兴奋。”当你不断打断这些消极的想法并用新想法代替它们时，这种重复意味着总有一天你会达到一种让它变得自动化的程度。你不需要去说服自己，你只需去相信它。你只需相信，也许这件事情的发生不是为了什么原因，而是它将带来某种你会在那段关系继续下去时错过的事物。
I really think that understanding that and having a more positive, not just positive, but a different mindset towards the end of a relationship, towards the need for closure, gets us to a point where we are not scared to let ourselves move on. And this is where the next step comes in. True closure is about facing, unfortunately, negative emotions. And sometimes what keeps us in the memory, of a relationship, what keeps us going back, what keeps us unable to move on, is knowing that the next step after that is going to be really painful. Once we acknowledge that the relationship is
我真的认为，理解这一点并对关系的结束、对寻找内心的完结抱有一种更加积极——不仅是积极，而且是不同的——心态，能让我们达到不再害怕让自己继续前行的状态。这就是接下来的步骤发挥作用的地方。真正的完结，不幸的是，是关于直面负面情绪。有时，让我们沉溺于一段关系的记忆中、让我们不断回味、让我们无法释怀的原因，正是因为我们知道接下来的那一步会非常痛苦。一旦我们承认这段关系
truly over, that there is no more that they can provide us that is going to make us feel better, there is no more bargaining. That is going to naturally trigger a lot of grief. And so we engage in avoidance. But when we allow ourselves to realize that, you know, true closure is about facing these negative emotions there will be hard times when we no longer avoid the tears we no longer avoid the fears about the future the anxieties the dark emotions but we find an outlet for that energy i really think that we get to a closer point of being able to live with these past experiences and the knowledge that they didn't work out it is not as scary as it has to be i also want to reassure you that subconsciously unconsciously thinking about this person
确实已经结束了，对方已经无法再提供任何能让我们感觉更好、不再有任何讨价还价的东西时，这自然会引发大量的悲伤。因此，我们会选择逃避。但当我们让自己意识到，你知道的，真正的完结在于直面这些负面情绪——会有艰难的时刻，当我们不再逃避眼泪、不再逃避对未来的恐惧、焦虑和黑暗情绪，而是为这些能量找到一个出口时——我真的认为，我们会更接近能够带着这些过去的经历以及它们“未能如愿”的认知生活下去的状态，而这一切并不像想象中那么可怕。我也想让你放心，潜意识里、无意识地想起这个人，
having them pop into your head does not mean that you are not ready to move on. Do not confuse that with a need to reach back out to this person. It is totally entirely normal to still have the occasional thought about them, especially if you've been with this person for a long time, or they are a friend who has been with you for your whole life, or the situation you're trying to find closure from, was particularly upsetting or traumatic or really frustrating. It takes a while for that memory to be dulled and to feel like it has a place.
或者他们突然出现在你的脑海里，并不意味着你还没有准备好继续前进。不要把这与需要重新联系这个人的需求混淆。偶尔还会想起他们是完全正常的，特别是当你和这个人在一起很长时间，或者他们是陪伴了你一生的朋友，又或者你试图从中释怀的情况特别令人沮丧、创伤或烦恼。这些记忆需要一段时间才会逐渐淡去，并感觉它们有了该有的位置。
I think we all know that weird feeling where you wake up after a dream that you've had about someone and you haven't seen them for months. And suddenly there they are popping up in your subconscious. Well, strangely, you just can't stop thinking about the things that you did, you know, two summers. go. You can't stop thinking about this situation. These are called memory flare-ups and they are totally normal. Especially when we are dreaming, our brain just tends to fire off a lot of random energy and that sparks old connections, old paths, old feelings. It doesn't say anything more than that. It is not a secret sign to you to reach out. It is not a secret sign that you are not ready for
我想我们都有过那种奇怪的感觉：醒来时梦到一个你已经几个月没见的人。突然之间，他们就出现在你的潜意识里。嗯，奇怪的是，你就是无法停止去想两年前的那个夏天你做过的事。你无法停止去想这种情况。这些被称为记忆闪回（flare-ups），它们完全是正常的。尤其是当我们做梦时，我们的大脑往往会释放大量随机的能量，从而点燃旧的连接、旧的路径和旧的情感。它没有别的意思，不是在暗示你主动联系。它也不是一个秘密的信号，暗示你还没有为
closure, that there is something left to be said. It's just likely that something in your own has subconsciously triggered these memories to reappear. It could also be what we call the anniversary effect if these memories are occurring around a significant date, maybe on Valentine's Day or their birthday or six months since your breakup. The anniversary effect is a term used in the PTSD space that refers to the tendency for us to start reliving past experiences and events when a significant date comes around. because it's the significance of that anniversary that cues our memories. So don't fear it.
完结做好准备，或者还有什么话没说。它只是可能表明你内心深处的某种东西在潜意识里触发了这些记忆的重现。如果这些记忆发生在某个重要的日期附近，比如情人节、他们的生日或者你们分手六个月纪念日，这也可能是我们所说的“周年纪念效应”。周年纪念效应是PTSD领域中的一个术语，指的是当重要日子到来时，我们会开始重新体验过去经历和事件的倾向。因为正是这种周年纪念的重要性触发了我们的记忆。所以不要害怕它。
There is no hidden message for you in this. You are not doing anything wrong. You are not, I think, unprepared for closure. Just let it come and let it go. The fourth step is around accountability. Now, I think we've taken this perspective for most of this episode of like, someone has wronged me, someone has left me, how do I find closure? How do I move past this experience?
这里面没有任何隐藏的信息。你没有做错任何事。我想你并没有为完结做好准备。让它来，也让它去吧。第四个步骤是关于责任感。现在，我想我们在这一集的绝大多数时候都持这种观点，即：有人伤害了我，有人抛弃了我，我该如何找到内心完结？我该如何超越这段经历？
sometimes though we have been the one who has done the wrong thing even if we didn't mean to and it's actually that urgent and that craving for closure that we have to reach out to that person is really just the urge to resolve the lingering guilt that we feel we want this other person to forgive us we want them to accept our apology because we weren't happy with our behavior and we cannot move on from this place of guilt and remorse and regret I think in those people moments, it's really important to actually examine the role you had to play in what ended up occurring. If you continue to ignore what is so blaringly obvious and wrong, maybe, about your behavior, it actually doesn't help you in the future. All it's going to do is ensure that you make that mistake
然而有时，我们自己才是那个做错事的人，即使我们并非有意为之。事实上，那种迫切想要联系对方、渴望得到完结的冲动，真的只是为了解决我们心中挥之不去的内疚感。我们希望对方原谅我们，我们希望他们接受我们的道歉，因为我们对自己的行为感到不满意，无法从这种负罪感、懊悔和遗憾中走出来。我认为在那些时刻，真正审视你在最终发生的事情中扮演的角色是非常重要的。如果你继续忽视那些关于你行为的、如此显而易见和错误的东西，它其实对你的未来没有任何帮助。它唯一能做的事就是确保你会再次犯
again and you go through what you are going through again with another person you care about, facing the same kind of emotional turmoil and regret and resentment even that you're feeling right now. Really take a solid, hard look at what about this situation were you responsible for? Did you not respect their boundaries, maybe? Did you overstep their boundaries? Were you not really on your best behavior? Was there something happening in your environment that you allowed to be projected onto them? What was your role in creating this situation? It's very easy to blame others, especially since we like to protect our self-esteem and we like to feel like we are good people. It is only natural to feel that way.
同样的错误，并和另一个你在乎的人再次经历你现在所经历的一切，感受到同样的内心情感动荡、遗憾甚至怨恨。真正坚定、深刻地审视在这场状况中你要负起什么责任？你是不是没有尊重他们的界限？也许你越界了？你是不是没有表现出最好的自己？你的环境中是否有某些事情，让你把它们投射到了对方身上？你在造成这种局势中扮演了什么角色？指责他人非常容易，特别是我们喜欢保护自己的自尊心，并且希望觉得自己是好人。有这种感觉是很自然的。
But the older you get, the more you realize that that really doesn't make you a better person. You're just suppressing the parts of you that might actually end up hurting other people. And this moment right now, this moment where you're looking for closure, is a great time to turn to yourself for answers. And turn to yourself for the promise that this won't happen in the future, because I'm going to take responsibility for my role in this. Finally, if you're looking for the closure that we have been talking about all along, you are unable to get it, you are searching high and low for some kind of answer or explanation
但随着你年龄的增长，你会越来越意识到，这其实并不能让你成为一个更好的人。你只是在压抑自己内心那些最终可能会伤害到其他人的部分。而此时此刻，这个你在寻求完结的时刻，正是向自己寻求答案的绝佳时机。向自己许下承诺：未来不会再发生这种情况，因为我要为自己在这件事中扮演的角色承担责任。最后，如果你一直在寻找我们刚才谈论的那种完结，却无法得到它，你正在四处寻找某种答案或解释，
for why this has happened. It might be time to do some further digging and further self-forgiveness, but also forgiveness of the other person for what is essentially the pain that you're experiencing, whether it is deliberate or accidental. So we've talked about this exercise before, but I want to speak about it again. This is around, it's like a letter writing exercise. And you're going to write two letters. You are going to write a final letter to this person, apologizing, acknowledging, expressing how hurt you feel. But why you are ready to let go, why now is the time that you are going to move on. I want you to write that letter and give as much
来明白为什么会发生这一切，也许是时候做更深入的挖掘和更彻底的自我宽恕了，同时也要原谅对方带给你的本质上的痛苦，无论是刻意还是无意的。我们以前讨论过这个练习，但我想再次谈谈它。这是关于写信的练习。你要写两封信。你要给这个人写最后一封信，表达歉意、承认事实、表达你感到的伤害。但也要说明为什么你准备放下了，为什么现在是你继续前行的时候。我希望你写下那封信，并提供尽可能多的
detail as possible. You are going to detail every emotion that you have felt, why it was directed towards them, the emotions that have been directed towards yourself, every confusing thing about this situation, everything that you are mad about, everything that you are maybe grateful for, write it in that letter and then get rid of it. I know this sounds super silly, but do something that symbolically kind of represents that you are like cleansing yourself of this past, kind of removing or cleansing yourself of
细节。你要详细写下你所感受到的每一个情绪、为什么这种情绪是针对他们的、那些针对你自己的情绪、关于这种情况的所有令人困惑的事情、所有让你生气的方面、所有你可能心存感激的事情，把它们写在那封信里，然后把信处理掉。我知道这听起来很傻，但做一些象征性的事情，代表你正在像净化自己一样摆脱过去，某种程度上移除或洗清你感受到的
the guilt that you're feeling or the sadness. Not going to promote arson, obviously, but like burning the letter is in a controlled space is actually really deeply moving because it does feel quite poetic and
内疚或悲伤。当然我不是在鼓励纵火，但在一个受控的空间里烧掉这封信其实是非常深刻且感人的，因为这确实感觉非常富有诗意和象征意义，
symbolic that you have had this pent up emotional landscape and pent up emotional state for so long that you're finally letting yourself physically, like, burn it down, physically destroy some of these emotions. That's the first letter, write the letter to them, and then write the letter to yourself, to the self, yourself right now who is experiencing this. What do they need to hear from you? Is it that it's going to get better? What do they need to hear about what you're feeling? Especially when we think about this in terms of,
你压抑了这么久的情感风景和情感状态，终于允许自己从物理层面将其焚烧殆尽，物理上摧毁其中一些情绪。这是第一封信，写给他们的信；然后写第二封信，写给你自己，写给现在正在经历这一切的你自己。他们需要从你这里听到什么？是事情会变好吗？他们需要听到关于你感受的什么？特别是当我们从以下角度思考时：
of reading it back in the future? What would you want to remember about this experience that is going to teach you something? And that it's going to serve as a landmark in three months, six months time for you to look back on and say, I've actually done a lot of work from here. I'm actually feeling a lot better. I am no longer in that like intense exaggerated state of needing, needing to see them, needing to get an answer, needing that closure like it's water. There's been a lot of research on these kinds of exercises. The first thing that they're really helpful with doing is preventing you from ruminating in your own mind over and over again about every small detail and therefore allowing yourself to kind of be beholden to these memories. But research has also
在未来回读它？关于这段经历，你希望记住什么能够教给你一些东西？它将成为三六个月后你回首过去的一个里程碑，让你对自己说：“我从这里出发，其实已经做了很多工作。我感觉好多了。我不再处于那种强烈的、夸张的、需要去见他们、需要得到答案、像渴望水一样需要那个完结的状态了。”关于这类练习有很多研究。它们真正有用的第一件事是防止你在脑海里反复咀嚼每一个微小的细节，从而让自己不再沦为这些记忆的奴隶。但研究也
shown that this type of writing that allows us to examine what we've lost through a redemptive lens without blame and that focuses on your current emotional state and focuses even sometimes on the positives, it can be very useful in helping us to achieve closure. Whereas when we simply just vent and rant to our friends, actually what you're doing is just maintaining this cycle of feeling like this situation, this person has control over you in some senses. I want to say this again. The answers do not lie in someone else. You can provide yourself with closure, whether that is through a mindset shift or a mindset shift or a kind of a cathartic release, making some changes to how you see yourself, but also understanding
表明，这种书写方式允许我们通过救赎的视角来审视我们所失去的东西，不带指责，专注于你当前的情绪状态，有时甚至专注于积极面，这对于帮助我们实现完结非常有用。然而，当我们只是向朋友宣泄和抱怨时，实际上你所做的一切只是维持了这样一种循环：让你觉得这种情境、这个人某种程度上仍然控制着你。我想再次强调这一点。答案并不在别人身上。你可以为自己提供完结，无论是通过心态的转变、通过情绪的宣泄、对自我认知的改变，还是去理解
that this relationship maybe had to end for a reason, this situation had to occur. There is something contained in this that you might not be able to see right now, but is really important for your journey. I think that that really allows us to come to peace with this situation and not feel like it has total control over who we are and who we're becoming. I want to say this final thing, but time seriously does heal all wounds. Your grip on these memories and this experience will loosen as time goes on and as those experiences are replaced with better ones and novel experiences as well and new things and new relationships and new people and new things to be happy about. So I really hope that this has provided you with an overview of why maybe you don't really need closure from someone else,
这段关系也许有其必须结束的理由，这种情况的发生是注定的。其中蕴含着某些你现在可能无法看到，但对你的旅程至关重要的事情。我认为这真的能让我们与这种状况达成平和，不再觉得它对我们是谁以及我们将成为谁拥有绝对的控制权。我想说的最后一件事是，时间真的能治愈一切伤口。随着时间的推移，当你经历被更好的事物、新奇的体验、新的事物、新的人以及新的幸福源泉所取代时，你对这些记忆和经历的执念将会减弱。所以我真的希望这为你提供了一个概述：为什么你可能并不真的需要别人的完结，
why you can provide it for yourself, some of the pitfalls of looking for closure and being desperate for it, and whatever you're going through, whether I described your situation or not, if this related to you in any way, I'm sending you a lot of love and a lot of strength. I know it can be incredibly difficult, but I think you're doing the right thing. You are obviously listening to content about this and you are searching for answers that lay beyond this other person or lay beyond these circumstances you can't control. So I'm proud of you. Congratulations. As always, if there is someone who needs to hear this episode, please feel free to share it with them. Make sure you have left a five-star review and that you
为什么你可以为自己提供完结，寻找完结的某些陷阱以及对它的绝望，无论你正在经历什么，无论我是否描述了你的情况，如果这在任何方面与你相关，我都向你发送许多爱和力量。我知道这可能会极其艰难，但我认为你正在做正确的事情。你显然在倾听有关这方面的内容，并且在寻找超越另一个人或超越你无法控制的环境的答案。所以我为你感到骄傲。祝贺你。和往常一样，如果有人需要听到这一集，请随时与他们分享。确保你留下了五星好评，并且
are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you have an episode suggestion, if you just want to say hi, if you have feedback, if you have any further tips for getting closure in these tough situations, I would love to hear from you. We will be back next week with another episode. Until then, stay safe. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
在Instagram上关注我们：@That Psychology Podcast。如果你有剧集建议、只想打个招呼、有任何反馈，或者对在这些艰难情况下如何获得完结有任何进一步的建议，我很乐意听到你的声音。我们下周将带着另一集回归。在此之前，请保持安全。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了坚韧意志、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的方法。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
收听《2%》。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO percent”。欢迎收听《The Look Back at it》播客。对1979年来说，那对我是一个巨大的时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black. people listen to look back at it on the iHeart radio app apple podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts hey what's good y'all you're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host care games this space is about black men's experiences having honest conversations that's really not safe
与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Care Games）带来的《从难处学起》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间关乎黑人群体的经历，进行那些在
to have anywhere but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing how many men carry a suit or armor it signals to the world that you're not to be played with and just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once.
其他任何地方都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着一副铠甲？它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着因为你有这种能力，你就必须这样做。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《从难处学起》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要一大群网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。吉莱斯皮（Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱网》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档iHeart播客。真人保证。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。